in this video i explain in a simple way
what the chi-square test is and how you
can calculate the chi-square test with
just a few steps
this leads us right to the first
question
what is the chi-square test
the chi-square test is a hypothesis test
that is used when you want to determine
whether there is a relationship between
two categorical variables or not
what are categorical variables
categorical variables are for example
gender with the characteristics male and
female
or the preferred newspaper where you
have the washington post the new york
times usa today
or for example the frequency of
television with several times a week
rare never
or the highest educational level of a
person
these are all categorical variables the
weight of a person for example or the
salary or the electricity consumption
are no categorical variables
so whenever we have two categorical
variables and we want to check if there
is a correlation between them we use a
chi-square test
we could for example be interested in a
question
if there is a relationship between
gender and the preferred newspaper or is
the relationship between gender and the
frequency of television another question
could be is there a relationship between
the preferred newspaper and the
frequency of television or finally in
the last example
is there a relationship between the
frequency of television viewing and the
highest level of education
therefore whenever we have two
categorical variables for which we want
to establish a relationship we use the
chi-square test
let's say we want to investigate the
relationship between gender and a
person's highest educational level our
question then would be is there a
relationship between gender and the
highest level of education for this
purpose we create a questionnaire where
the participants mark their gender and
their highest level of education the
result of this survey is displayed in an
excel table in this table we see one
person in each row that we have surveyed
the first person we interviewed is male
and the highest educational level is
college the second person we interviewed
is female and she is without graduation
we can now take this table and copy it
into a statistical software like data
tab data that then outputs the so called
cross table in this table you see the
variable gender and the variable highest
educational level and also how often in
each case the combination occurs female
and without graduation occur six times
in a table or male and without
graduation occurs altogether seven times
in this table now we want to know
whether gender has an influence on the
highest educational level does it make a
difference if i'm female or male in
terms of the highest education and level
i have in other words is there a
relationship between gender and the
highest educational level
in order to answer this question we use
the chi-square test
now there are two ways how to calculate
the chi-square test
either we use a statistical software
like data tab or we calculate the
chi-square test by hand we get started
with the uncomplicated way and use
datadep afterwards i will show you how
you can calculate the chi-square test by
hand
in order to do this
simply visit datadept.net
you will find the link in the video
description
now you click on statistics calculator
and copy your own data into this table
the variables will now appear here below
because of the fact that the variable's
values are in words data tab assumes
that they are categorical variables if
your data is coded with numbers you have
to change the scale level under variable
view we want to calculate the chi-square
test so i just click here on the tab
now we simply click on the variables
gender and highest educational level and
data tab will automatically suggest the
appropriate test for you in this case
the chi-square test now we immediately
get the results for the chi-square test
we see the cross table for the
variable's gender and highest
educational level
here we can see the expected frequencies
for perfectly independent variables
and finally here are the results of the
chi-square test and we get a p-value of
0.92
if you don't know how to interpret the
results you can simply have a look at
the summary in words
a car square test was performed between
gender and highest educational level
no expected cell frequencies were less
than five there was no statistically
significant relationship between gender
and highest educational level
we use state adapt to calculate a
chi-square test let's say we choose a
significance level of 5
then we reject the null hypothesis
if we get a p-value that is smaller than
0.05
we got a p-value of 0.981
which is of course much larger than 0.05
and thus we don't reject the null
hypothesis
based on these data there is no
relationship between gender and the
highest educational level and now let's
calculate the chi-square test by hand
in order to calculate the chi-square
test by hand we need the crosstab with
the observed frequencies and the cross
step with the expected frequencies we
get the expected frequencies by looking
at which frequencies we should actually
get if there was no relationship between
gender and highest educational level we
can now calculate the chi-square value
using the following formula here ok is
the observed frequency of a cell and e k
is the expected frequency of the
respective cell if we now apply this
formula to our example we get the
following from the first cell we
calculate the observed frequency 6
minus the expected frequency which is
6.08 square that and divide that by the
expected frequency we now do the same
for the second cell
7 minus 6.92
squared divided by 6.92
if we do this for all cells and sum it
up we get our chi-square value which is
0.504
if you use a statistical software like
data tab you get the p-value returned
however calculating the p-value by hand
is not feasible
therefore in this case we use the
so-called critical chi-square value we
can read the critical chi-square value
in this table you can find this table on
datatab.net
the link is in the video description
here we have a five percent significance
level so we are in that column the
degrees of freedom are obtained by
multiplying the number of rows
minus one by the number of columns minus
one we have four rows and two columns so
we get three times one which equals
three so we are in this row in the table
now this gives us a critical chi-square
value of 7.815
our calculated chi-square value is
smaller than the critical value so the
null hypothesis is not rejected
if you like check out data tab you will
find many more tutorials there
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time